(upbeat music)
- A liberated woman
is one who has sex
before marriage and a job after.
Women have two choices,
either she's a feminist
or a masochist.
- [Voiceover] Chloe Grace
Moretz is Gloria Steinem.
- Jesus, what a
bossy, naggy Nancy.
God, and the shrill voice.
Does it remind you of
Britney or what you guys?
- Okay you realize that
that's a huge compliment.
- Oh my bad.
- Kevin's just
bummed because the
cisgender white male is done.
Witness the future Father Time.
- Hey guys can I
ask you something?
Do your bosses ever make you
ask inappropriate questions?
- I don't understand
the question.
- I once asked Jennifer
Lawrence what her cup size was.
- You asked her that on camera?
- Never mind.
- I guess my site wants
to get into gossip
because numbers
are a little flat.
They want me to ask Chloe
about who she's dating.
- That's always a winner for me.
- That sucks.
- I just feel weird,
you know, as a grown man
asking a young girl
about her love life.
- How else are you going to
know if she's available, man?
- Okay, you guys are all idiots
and you clearly know
nothing about feminism
because you're men, so just
stick to non controversial
subjects like her diet
secrets or refugees.
So the movie, oh my god.
I loved it, as a woman,
Gloria Steinem has been a huge
influence on me since I
googled her a half hour ago.
I honestly thought like women
were always equal with men.
- You never dealt with
any discrepancy there?
- No, because like
in our generation
things are different for us.
I think we're
around the same age.
Right, like early 20s?
- I'm sure.
- Yeah early mid late 20s, 30s.
- I'm 19.
- Okay yeah, so like
around the same age.
- How you doing, you
doing good today?
- Yeah.
- You look great,
anyways, did you want
to talk about this
movie or can we just
stick on Little Mermaid?
- I'm here promoting this, so.
- Right.
- [Chloe] I think we
should talk about that.
- They warned me
you would kind of be
like this, but that's
cool, whatever.
- Oh man, you know, I'm such
a big fan of all your work.
Like Gloria's
great, but of course
I gotta bring up Kick-Ass.
It's so great
because Hit-Girl is
not afraid to just hit people.
- I don't really agree with
violence, it's a movie.
- Oh yeah, me neither.
- It's all art and fun.
- It's just that people,
some of the people
I work with are so mean to me.
It's like the prettier they
are, the meaner they are.
If I could be like.
- I mean frankly she
changed the world.
- Let's not get too
carried away here, okay?
I mean she put a
silly little idea
in a lot of girls'
heads that they could
go out there and be the
boss of somebody okay?
That's not written in
any playbook I know.
It's not even in the Bible.
I mean what did
Glo-glo here really do
when you think about it?
- Wow.
First of all, no
one's even speaking
about menstruation before her.
- You know what, let's
just keep this classy okay?
You don't need to
get disgusting here.
We got to put this on TV.
- You're a Neanderthal.
You understand that right?
No wonder everyone says
you're gonna get fired soon.
- All right missy, I don't think
you need to get
rude with me here.
- You literally can't
handle the word vagina.
(gags)
Uterine wall.
- Ugh.
- Fallopian tubes.
- Oh god, oh ew.
- Ovaries.
- Ew, ew, ew!
I was wrong.
Chloe Grace Moretz
has the upper hand.
She's a little monster.
- We're about ready
for you, and just
a friendly reminder, stick
to the film okay, great.
- Hey, buddy.
You owe it to America to keep
them stupid and entertained
so go be that guy, okay soldier?
- [Voiceover] Name
and affiliation?
- Brian Butler The Downloader.
- Oh my god, I know you.
I've read your work.
You're actually a
really good writer.
- Oh wow, thanks.
You've read my work?
- Yeah well you're
like a real journalist
unlike those fools out there.
I mean they're total clowns.
They have no idea
what they're doing.
What do you want to ask me?
- So now that you've
had the chance to play
a feminist icon, how
has that influenced
your outlook on being a
woman in today's society?
- Thank you so much
for actually asking me
a question that means something.
Gloria came of age in
a very oppressive time.
It just made me feel very
honored and privileged
to be a young woman
in the time period
that we're living in right now.
- Such a smart answer.
You're such a smart
lady who I'm sure
could talk on any number
of interesting subjects.
- Yeah, I'd love to.
You okay?
- Yeah no, we're probably
out of time right?
We're good?
- No we have, we have time.
- Ask me another question.
- These things
just really fly by.
- No, I'm like
actually enjoying this.
- Oh, great.
So.
(clears throat)
Who're you dating?
- What was that?
- Who are you dating?
- Sorry I can't, I can't
hear what you're saying.
- Who are you dating?
- Are you serious?
- I'm so sorry,
I'm just a soldier.
You know what I mean like,
we all do what we gotta do.
- I am here doing press
for Gloria Steinem.
You come in here and you ask
me who I'm fucking dating!
- I'm so sorry.
- Who am I dating?
- I had marching orders.
- Get out.
Get out of my room.
- Come on there's more.
- Go, go!
I actually liked you!
I wanted you to interview me!
And you fucked it up!
- Hey.
- [Britney] You okay?
- You guys have a key?
- [All] No.
- No they don't
give those to us.
- Should I text someone?
- Chlo?
- Are you going by
the vending machines?